Hausa go press but it's perfect
welcome back to palm gets why fine let
me see the pictures yeah yeah any photos
of course that you think we'd had over
photos of God friend to a creep like
she's our friend since the wedding
what did you just call me a lahar
bernard is like this [ __ ] now feel
bad if anyone has a Bernards dog or
whatever you better get on your knees
right now and beg for forgiveness
try an egg bag good know Christmas
that wasn't tough guy at all Lucas mr.
tough guy all of a sudden oh I see how
it is I feel like I would be Bernard if
I was a dog but you have a thing for
Chris too don't you
you rot them puke brain [ __ ] [ __ ]
Paul that's the bestest is ever huh now
you [ __ ] up now you [ __ ] up you
[ __ ] up we're gonna fight him take
back what you say Shiva doesn't have a
thing for Christ okay okay he does it
now say I ship huh / CB what hey I I
ship huh / evening are you happy now
for now anyway well sobbing like a boss
to tell you we shall shown he that's
what happens when you have bad ships
that's the whole reason you attacked him
[Music]
this father is like the best character
ever I ship I ship officially my first
ship ever is hostile /e but now just
because of that let's do a quick save
save you says now okay okay so this is
where we left off in the last episode so
multi or whatever saying not unless
you're willing to throw comic sama
himself
overthrow kami-sama you mean dog
I just realized also that dog is God
backwards
so if dog has defeated this place
existence will be in jeopardy try to
make that face that it'll focus sacred
might be possible day but other throw
dog is I even possible a dog is kinda
though what a bag is gonna do why does
he show her ass to me why I like it okay
so we have to kill God or dog or ever to
be less offensive I like this music it's
pretty sweet
alright so who the hell are you are you
God I lost my cookies I don't get that
fun I had the geese important a little
opening Gator dodge strong bow how
convenient
we'll find your card kills where did you
lie to them
I think I might and wrap them in the
trash the [ __ ] I got a final you let
yeah he left
we should find those keys that gives
them all right
Bobby you really plan to fight dog you
can't do that
I'm not coming with you Nami
come on come on Jimmy Sebastian no I
don't know for this I'll show you what
happens when you defy me I won't let you
touch it No what's happening hold this
oh my god is HUS Shiva get back
oh my [ __ ] god gay boyfriend do the
rest
I can't handle this great Foley again
fine you can take him
I am a strong independent pom pom
doggies whoa don't need no shimmy
that damn chibi good
this game just got better and better I
don't I didn't expect that that's great
alright somebody actually shave me it's
pretty annoying honestly what are you
doing here
I'm so pooped after working out do I
look pretty stronger
no that's so nice of you okay let's do
another save we're never really went in
here
oh this looks like a lot of trash to me
huh what's that hey Jamie as kids
strikes again I found the car keys hey
you get your take out go bad for you I
need them how about I trade you this for
this root beer float from certain you
have you have start you have a root beer
float okay deal
well that was easy
you wouldn't believe what some people
throw away I believe it
what okay it's time to overthrow
Kamisama himself found a cookies and
open the gate in defeat dog wait keep
the car keys to me
no the pun is too bad I don't get the
pun
Corky's you can't see dar without his
permission
why are you even listening to Obama what
time yes we can now that's a good pun
okay whoa stop
Oh No what's gonna happen
Tom you can't fight dog objection go
away we're gonna fight
don't fight no [ __ ] way you do I
going down
sorry shipping looks like I have no
choice
well this should be easy anyway there we
go hell yeah bruh
oh no they died well they both are
they're both not die from them I should
pee on their bodies
stupid chibi okay let's go meet God
through the rainbow oh are you okay we
I'm not even going to question how you
got him
well I guess you're kind of by saying
that oh okay I wonder who dog is I bet
it's a pug wait what the [ __ ] is that
it's a French Bulldog dog who dares show
herself to me it is I the one who's
going to kick your ass imputed water you
think you can defeat me
they are Almighty vows that I'm so
scared
what are you going to do shoot me with a
gun that looks like a paint roller let
me show you my real power isn't even my
final form damn it there's so many
references in stupid puns in this game
you cannot grasp your true form of dr.
dey oh damn that does a lot of damage
I'm in that zone autosome oh oh wait you
do way more damage than that sorry I
think we should break up
it's not you it's a beep
[Laughter]
for without me this place existence will
crumble and fall into the world I'm
living the only one who can prevent that
from happening as yet the new dog
cool story bro wow he's late again I
guess now that I'm dog I can erase
targets for you muffled rap music plays
in the distance Tom are you okay your
fire
I'm better than okay I'm dark all I have
to do now is wait for this place to fall
apart enough for that Wi-Fi to show up
fall apart you can't let that happen
yeah I'm getting real tired of your
[ __ ] let's end this once and for all
so I'm getting the bad ending I like
this music
Paul listen to me there's got to be a
better way than this
sorry Simon I know Wi-Fi is important to
you but it doesn't have to be this way
you don't understand
I need Wi-Fi like I need a I don't need
anything else the internet affects
essence of my entire existence I can
relate to this your job have to be like
this your dog you have the power to do
anything right now literally anything
there are so many things that only you
can do just think about it you can make
the frisbee machine so that it never
breaks you can erase every spider in the
world you can live in a violence and
fighting you can make it so dogs like
but now I can creep on others I can't
keep another you can't pick so many
things that are wrong and if you just
get an action to make an effort to
change em if you don't show it no one
will know what else cat what should we
do bras should we kill him please don't
just sit here surfing the web while
there was falling apart around you but
that's all I know how to do that's deep
all I know how to do is sit in front of
it's too late I've never done anything
useful in my entire life
it's never too late to start not for
this not for anything
you can't change your past but you can
change your future and if we keep
looking I'm sure they'll find another
way to get Wi-Fi figure something out
the suspense for us their suspense
so please don't give everything up you
need to save the world right now I
believe in your palm
you can't Joe Mitch you don't need to be
afraid of anything
I know it's hard but please do something
Shiva's crying really hard you really
think I can do anything your dark of
course again I can will a sequel of the
world ends without you into existence
I could make watching book canno
mandatory for dark but I know that
anyway who wants to exist I can have the
staff of the memory no own hottie make
six what Olly [ __ ] but before you get
Raju all that right I need to do the
thing stopping doggy heaven from falling
apart yeah
how do I do the phone you don't know
[ __ ] what do I do
[ __ ] get ahold of yourself you stupid
ass up here but I'll [ __ ] another
[ __ ] piss on you oh that worked I'll
remember that
future references it's piss on it hey
back i am shaving chibi are you okay I'm
fine I'm fine
don't just a bear on me like that
I was really worried something bad
happen to you
oh sorry I'll try not to do it again
well what happened to you yeah you look
kind of different
I killed bad so I'm dog now that make
sense oh okay then wait you guys look
out okay with that
why wouldn't we be all the old dog ever
did was sit around here and act like it
was better than us typical french
bulldog behavior he never bothered to
talk to us or anything we tried to stop
you because we were worried about you
no we were wrong you didn't need saving
you're different from all Dom we can
trust you what the [ __ ] is this all
coming from what did I even do to
deserve this is the obvious you're a
friend that's great and all but I still
don't have Wi-Fi I'm sure that if we all
work together we'll find a way somehow
at least a way better than crashing this
whole place down on earth
okay I guess that was a bad idea I'll
talk about understatement now what
should I do fine there's so much to be
done
being a mega guy is suffering what I can
move okay
[Music]
that was a really nice game I I expected
something like this I didn't expect it
to be this good at least it was really
really fun to play through it was deep
too you know you know in a tiny way but
still silly it had a message fan and I
like that so it's pretty pretty good I'm
gonna do the other ending - oh he
doesn't have a dog well you should get a
pug they're the best let's do the ending
where we kill like she been
okay let's kill him in my CB wow talk
about overkill that's kind of sad I
failed I'm sorry everyone
oh no oh no my wife is back at lad I can
check details let's see what I have here
Tom it's not too late to apply palm pixi
yourself at berkeley I'm a [ __ ]
Pomeranian what the hell do you guys
want from me hey it's my svt question of
the day the late did not sure why I
signed up for that I don't need anyone I
don't even feel bad but I got nothing
happy and that was happy and okay so she
killed God or dog and everyone all her
friends just so she can go on the
Internet
I make sense anyway they were like your
gin joint watching this let's play it's
been a lot of fun that's it subscribe to
come over today and I'll seen whatever
else we did it all comes down you sucker